first question how are we going to fund
this we've planned to build the four new
submarines in our ten-year equipment
program we published in January the cost
will be spread over some 20 years but
this is a decision we need to take now
it was always programmed for next year
so we're committing very clearly in our
manifesto that we will renew our four
nuclear submarines and the real danger
now for four weeks time is that if you
vote Labour you could well end up with
us losing the nuclear submarines because
of the agreement that the SMP are likely
to do to prop up Mr Miliband in power on
that point in a moment but I just want
it to get a clarification how much it's
going to cost because we have heard from
Nicola Sturgeon of the SNP who's saying
that's going to cost 100 billion pounds
we've costed it at around 25 billion
pounds and that cost remember is spread
over yes but it spread over 20 to 30
years and is a price well worth paying
to keep this country safe that's a
decision every successive government has
taken for the last 50 60 years and it's
something that's now in doubt because
she has said this is a red line that she
will not cross she will not prop up a
Labour government so there's a real risk
here for voters in England as well as
Scotland that if you vote for David
Miliband for Edward Miliband you could
end up with us losing our nuclear
submarines well the Labour Party say
that's frankly scaremongering it's a red
line for them and they're absolutely
committed to renewing Trident and
although they're open to looking at
perhaps cheaper alternatives if it needs
to be for submarines as you're saying
you will commit to them they'll do the
same well we looked at the alternatives
we looked at all the different of costs
whether there was a cheaper system and
this is actually a submarine based
system is the cheapest way of continuing
the nuclear deterrent but look you can't
be sure if you end up there if you vote
for labor for weeks today you can't be
sure what kind of coalition might emerge
and the SNP have made it crystal clear
that this is a red line for them that
they will not tolerate the renewal of
the deterrent so you'll have ambiguity
the only way to be absolutely certain
that you'll retain Britain's nuclear
deterrent is to vote conservative and
that is the commitment we're make
today and that is the speech that you're
going to be making later on today and
indeed you've written in The Times today
about this very issue I just wanted to
ask you how exactly ed Miliband's
relationship with his brother is in any
way relevant to national security or
indeed trident well this is an issue of
trust we have to be absolutely sure that
we're going to keep our deterrent and if
you vote Labour there is the uncertainty
it could end up in a coalition and he
could be forced to bargain away the
nuclear deterrence about five years the
Liberal Democrats said in their
manifesto quite clearly in 2010 that
they were opposed to trident and that
they weren't interested in renewing it
and that they wanted nuclear disarmament
yes but we were able to form a
government with them on the basis that
they could vote against it she has made
it absolutely clear for the SNP that
they will not support a future Labour
government if they're if there's going
to be a renewal of the submarine so that
is the that is the risk as country faces
not simply higher taxes and higher
borrowing but weaker defenses if we end
up with some kind of unholy alliance
between labor and the SMP that's the
risk the only way to be absolutely
certain is to vote conservative in four
weeks time I still don't understand why
a big opportunity to launch a manifesto
pledge as you're doing today has to
disintegrate into something so personal
and there's one of the reasons why a lot
of people think that politics is so
toxic descending the language used
describing Mr Miliband is weakened
having a lust for power a backstabber
that he backs tagged his brother and he
would do the same now to the country I
mean it does smack a little bit of
desperation no I mean clearly ed
Miliband is going to be in a weak
position if he has to cobble together a
government with the SNP who will not
support the renewal of our nuclear
deterrent so this is an issue of trust
and certainty if you want to be
absolutely sure that we're going to keep
up this nation's defenses then you've
got to stay and vote conservative
otherwise you don't know what you could
end up with you could end up with higher
taxes more borrowing weaker defense and
a coalition where the SMP will be
driving the the labor I future Labour
government they'll be propping it up if
you want to make the case for trident
why don't we have a sin
we'll debate about that and the need for
submarines how they will protect our
shores what the international threats
might be rather than about a personality
a personal attack on somebody's family I
mean you know ed miliband and his
brother ran a fair contest but they both
entered into willingly I don't see how
it's relevant well this is in the end an
issue as I say of judgment and of trust
and the British people need to be clear
when they vote in four weeks time
exactly what they're voting for now we
can't be clear with labor because you've
heard from the SMP but they're talking
about Trident when we talk about that
why aren't we talking about you know the
issues surrounding it the cards where it
must be built what the benefits will be
sure but that's but Trident is the issue
that the SNP is saying is there red line
they will not prop up a future labour
government unless he gets rid of the
submarines now we are making today our
position absolutely pleased with the
headline saying backstabber mr miliband
I mean that's not necessarily where the
debate should be going that's my
argument well it's where the debate is
going because I mean indicative of the
conservative campaign that we're going
to see over the course the next four
weeks it's just going to be personal
slush and mud slinging no we're not
slinging mud we're setting out very
clearly what our commitment is and it's
for Mr Miliband to explain how he would
deal with a possible Labour government
that is propped up by the SMP that has
said very clearly and they say we are
offering to make ad Miliband prime
minister but only on condition that he
gets rid of the nuclear deterrent now
we're sitting out very clearly that that
kind of back stairs deal is simply
unacceptable you can't gamble away
Britain security with some kind of
grubby backroom deal to appease the SNP
in Scotland this is an issue that
affects the whole of Britain it's
Britain's security that's at risk and in
four weeks time we want to be absolutely
sure that people know what they're
voting for and they're voting for a
position of certainty you know viewers
at home who watching this are emailing
and getting in touch you're asking why
we're talking about Edmund abandoned his
relationship with his brother and indeed
if you say it's not mudslinging and we
can't expect more mudslinging then you
use the words back
being his own brother and that he will
now backstab the nation do you not
accept that that's mudslinging no this
is I said an issue of trust and of
character and we need to be clear
whether or not you're prepared to
support our nuclear deterrent we've made
it clear we are going to renew those
submarines if you if you vote Labour you
could end up because of the SNP position
you could end up with a coalition where
ed miliband does some grubby deal behind
the scenes with Nicola Sturgeon of the
SMB and we need to get that out into the
open so that people know in four weeks
time exactly what they're voting for